I'm sorry stock of Winterfell this is my
home and you can't frighten me Sansa is
all about self-confidence on Game of
Thrones but in real life sophie turner
admits it took her some time to find it
it's all inside the June issue of Marie
Claire Australia the 23 year old opens
up about her struggles with mental
health an issue that was only made worse
by being asked to lose weight for the
HBO show quote my metabolism suddenly
decided to fall to the depth of the
ocean and I started to get spotty and
gain weight and all of this was
happening to me on camera according to
the magazine then came pressure from
film and television studios to lose
weight the character that I play on my
show is called Sansa and people used to
write like a damn Sansa gained 10 pounds
or Sansa needs to lose 10 pounds really
yeah it was just a lot of weight
comments Sophie recently opened up about
mental health and her weight in an
interview with dr. Phil it just got very
very self-conscious I was be concerned
about angles I'd be concerned about my
face I have like a big nose and so I
would like I don't know how to angle
myself and it would just affect me
creatively and I couldn't be true to the
character because I was so worried about
Sophie one person who's helped her is
new husband Joe Jonas I have a shoulder
to cry on so it's good I'm so happy they
just tied the knot in a surprise Las
Vegas wedding on Wednesday night
a source tells ET that while the Vegas
wedding was about having fun and living
in the moment the couple does plan to
have a more formal wedding with their
family and friends but this ceremony was
just fun Joe and Sophie are planning to
get married in Paris later this year
with this ring
you
[Music]